paso firme en este día de elecciones
Lola Vázquez no deja que nada se
interponga Entre ella y su derecho a
votar
pero hace unos años atrás sufragar era
una experiencia violenta para la
población transgénero de Guatemala
ni la fotografía entonces tenía así el
temor de que no se me dejara votar pero
en esa oportunidad las compañeras de
acompañamiento y pues prueba de que
tiene también a minimizar un poco esa
discriminación Lola y sus compañeras se
organizaron para conformar un
observatorio y así asegurarse de que no
sufran discriminación en los centros de
votación hoy lo la asesora Irene quien
vota por primera vez desde su proceso de
transición tienes que votar sin miedo no
te pueden negar el voto es un derecho
que tenemos sabemos que es tu primera
vez como mujer trans es muy importante
que pues no no tengas una mala
experiencia a la hora de ejercer este
derecho pero el derecho a la
representación No ha sido la única lucha
de las personas trans de Guatemala mucho
gusto este como ya sabes es un espacio
seguro donde tenés el derecho a la salud
que es un derecho que siempre se nos ha
negado ante el maltrato en los centros
de salud Alexa abierto una clínica para
atender a hombres transexuales hoy
recibe a Leo quien huyó de su pueblo
natal después de sufrir discriminación
público insisten en tratarte en nuestro
caso de manera femenina y con un nombre
con el cual no no nos identificamos y
nos han pedido incluso certificaciones
de psiquiatras un estudio del colectivo
evidencio que la violencia empieza desde
el círculo familiar al ex lo vivió
cuando fue casado a los 17 años con un
hombre que lo maltrataba hoy al igual
que Lola trabaja incansablemente para
proteger la diversidad de identidad en
todos los espacios públicos de Guatemala